kaylee cuoco and husband carl cook are
going their separate ways
can you tell us about carl cook is here
tonight
why him so cute because he's perfect the
35 year old actress and 30 year old
equestrian made the announcement in a
joint statement they write quote despite
a deep love and respect for one another
we have realized that our current paths
have taken us in opposite directions we
have both shared so much of our journey
publicly so while we would prefer to
keep this aspect of our personal life
private we want it to be forthcoming in
our truth together there is no anger or
animosity quite the contrary the couple
goes on to say that they made the
decision to split together and have an
immense amount of respect and
consideration for one another
it's all about gratefulness kaylie and
carl both equestrians started dating in
2016 and it was clear the actress was
head over heels why is he so special
he's so real i've never met a kinder
human being he's gentle and he's real
and i'm completely in love with him
nothing could be better just a few weeks
after kaley said that to e.t the pair
got engaged on her 32nd birthday
honey
how do you feel honey
what's on your finger honey
we're engaged
they wed the following june in a lavish
ceremony at a horse stable near san
diego there were really not enough words
to describe how i actually truly feel
about you and by november they were
still basking in newlywed bliss
do things change when you actually get
married is the love deeper i feel that
it is i know some people say it
shouldn't change it should be the same
you love you know but for me it did i'm
i'm just so happy to come home to him
every day he's my dream guy
do you feel the same way
i know you're trying to make a joke
right now but you can't think of one can
you well he's trying to mess with me how
correct i should be right now yes no
it's great it's great i think it's just
you just
learn
to be better together yeah and and
that's the joy that it is and
and we're lucky that we both share the
same loves for animals and all that's
kind of what brought us together in the
first place so it's uh we have a lot in
common last june they celebrated their
third wedding anniversary with touching
tributes to one another on instagram
kaylee shared this image and jokingly
asked in the caption why have you stayed
married to me for so long i'm sincerely
impressed i love you oh so much you have
no idea happy anniversary
carl posted this and added i agree i am
just as amazed it's been three years
feel like just a flash i love you so
much and i can't wait for a million more
years
[Music]
you